welcome to this video play there's
Martha Kent star from ya from South
Africa actually by the Italian flag
Kenny Solomon was its Salamone let me
check Solomon okay um back to this
testing him in the NQ ga I have not
really learned that line yet but trying
it out anyway Adria thank you go back b3
that's not very common I wonder ever can
go will see 5 in this position or maybe
maybe I can prepare that right I mean
see if I this Bishop b5 check which is a
bit irritating let's prepare that yeah
that shouldn't be bad at all pretty
solid position so what is he going to do
okay I'm taking you just keep it simple
pawn takes would be would be weird that
would be a weird i QP so what is he
doing Queen takes Queen takes I was
thinking we should have three but yeah
on knight c6 me knight c6 cannot
possibly be bad really just just develop
feels very equal this kind of planning
his he's a grandmaster by the way I'm
sorry if I said I am but he does not
adjusted this in the ISIS if he got the
Grandmaster tons were winning the
African championships i think last year
or this year a lot quite sure but very
recently
yeah this is rule that you can get the
GM title by winning your continental
championships it's an interesting
interesting concept but I always thought
that this was a little bit yeah at the
same time a little bit unfair and and
and both interesting certainly not a bad
idea to promote chess and in areas that
are a little bit of the map let's say
like Africa for example but on the other
hand it makes getting the GM title and
Africa much easier by winning this event
I mean this is no offense but but I'm
not in any way worse than mr. Solomon
and I cannot just win the European
Championships like that on the other
hand I think it's certainly good
promotion to have an African Grandmaster
or South African Grandmaster for chance
in that country or in this area of the
world okay so what do we have here as I
said pretty equal ish position he tries
to why he is going for further for the
trade him Jim I can just take this
not sure if I want want to do that g7
can be hanging at some point this is a
little bit annoying okay I'm taking
maybe this he's slightly his slightly
had in development so a little bit
concerned if he takes and plays Roxy one
for example I'm looking like one or two
moves then I'm totally fine like f6
Kingda seven or something along these
lines then I'd really be fine but I
don't don't have that at the moment
don't have that plate at the moment
maybe I can solve my issues with a
common with a coming 'if I've i am and i
also have h 5 by the way that's an
interesting idea now with the rook on
the fifth rank hmm yeah let's do this
keep it simple I have that Bishop a3
move as well that at low temp okay now
what is the idea efore not quite sure
I prevent c5 by taking twice that's
certainly true maybe age five I don't
you four look these six and I don't see
anything bad happening to me
huh they're probably that wasn't so
great allowing this him five maybe it
looks kind of me
yeah I have to take I think have to take
to simplify matters playing for bishop
is similar gauge for something I have to
have to have to get this back now or
luke h5 is also an alternative yeah it's
a bit more bit more aggressive and well
aggressive is a strong word but maybe a
little bit more interesting hey it's got
g6g success as a simple end and decent
move I a bishop chicks kingi for ha good
mouth
yeah tactics are important nice move
check no I'm strong morning no I'm
struggling a little bit him with the
porn being weak the age pole
bloody each pawn check check it's not so
easy for him to do anything though no
prom king is several have to do her
anyway growling mudra here I've got more
time draw our third rah rah rah yeah
they are playing this on time as kind of
ridiculous I'm still worse how did I do
that was that really necessary maybe age
force be too I wanted a well he did all
at all is all about that that keenya
three tactic and this is this is not a
good idea to do this I didn't see that
that idea yeah I think I should be
somewhat some shouldn't be okay I'll
leave is he really better here with that
age sorry with that age poor check check
yeah the H part is a bit vulnerable it
really is yeah maybe edge for wasn't a
good idea I don't know I can definitely
play something conservative here like
this yeah white has a little bit more
space but it really shouldn't be
anything relevant yeah it's nice the h4
was better what's really bad check check
check I wonder where way we will check
okay yes sir doin this snow and go over
here maybe or OB aid yeah why twins yeah
I was a really lucky escape there oh
thanks for watching